CURRENT PRIME MINISTER CONCEDES
DEFEAT.
BUT FIRST TONIGHT, PAKISTAN'S
FORMER PRIME MINISTER, IMRAN
KHAN, IS ACCUSING SENIOR
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS OF
ORCHESTRATING AN ASSASSINATION
ATTEMPT AGAINST HIM, INCLUDING
CURRENT PRIME MINISTER, SHEHBAZ
SHERIFF, AS WELL AS OTHERS.
BUT THEY DENIED IT.
HAHN WAS SHOT IN THE LOWER LEG
AND THIGH, WHEN THE GOVERNMENT
OPENED FIRE AT A RALLY ON
THURSDAY.
HE'S LISTED, IN STABLE
CONDITION.
BUT A PARTY OFFICIAL SAYS,
PELOTON LODGED IN HIS LEG AND
THE BONE --
THIS VIDEO SHOWS CAN, AS YOU
CAN SEE, THEY'RE FLEEING THE
SCENE.
ONE OTHER PERSON WAS KILLED AND
SEVERAL FORMER'S WERE ALSO
INJURED.
I WANT TO GO TO SOPHIA --
WHO IS LIVE FOR US IN ISLAM
ISLAMABAD, PAKISTAN.
GOOD TO SEE.
YOU JUST BRING US UP TO DATE ON
HOW THIS ALL UNFOLDED AND HOW
HE'S DOING THIS HOUR.
>> ISA, THIS HAPPENED IN THE
DISTRICT OF BOOTS HAVE ALL OF.
THERE IS A LOT OF UNEASE IN THE
COUNTRY AT THE MOMENT THE
PROTESTS ACROSS THE COUNTRY IN
RESPONSE TO WHAT'S HAPPENED TO
HIM RUN KHAN.
THERE HAVE BEEN MONTHS OF
POLITICAL POLARIZATION AND
UNEASE, LEADING UP TO WHAT
HAPPENED TODAY.
HERE'S OUR REPORT ON HOW THE
EVENTS OF TODAY UNFOLDED.
>> IN THE CHAOTIC MOMENTS AFTER
THE SHOOTING, IMRAN KHAN HAD TO
BE CARRIED OUT AND WHISKED AWAY
FROM THE CROWD.
A GUNMAN HAD OPENED FIRE AT A
RALLY OF TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
HIS SUPPORTERS.
HIS TARGET, KHAN ONE'S PARTY
SAYS, WAS THE FORMER PRIME
MINISTER HIMSELF.
SHOT IN THE LOWER LEG, HE WAS
BUNDLED INTO A BULLETPROOF CAR
AND DRIVEN TWO HOURS TO THE
HOSPITAL FOR SURGERY.
A PARTY SENIOR LEADER REALLY
STATEMENT FROM KHAN SAYING,
PAKISTAN'S OLD CRICKETING HERO
AND PRIME MINISTER, SHABHAZ
SHARIF, HIS INTERIOR MINISTER,
AND HIS SENIOR INTELLIGENCE
OFFICIAL FOR AN ATTEMPT ON HIS
LIFE.
CALLING FOR THEIR REMOVAL FROM
OFFICE.
IT WAS THE GOVERNMENT SAID, A
GRIEVOUS ACCUSATION.
OUTSIDE THE HOSPITAL, PEOPLE
WAITED DESPERATELY FOR NEWS.
PROTESTS BROKE OUT ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AS NEWS OF THE SHOOTING
SPREAD.
SIX OTHERS WERE INJURED IN THE
ATTACK AND ONE WAS KILLED,
ACCORDING TO A SENATOR FROM
KHAN'S POLITICAL PARTY.
POLICE PLEASE PRAY FOR IMRAN
KHAN, FOR OUR FELLOW WORKERS
WHO ARE INJURED.
THE SENATOR SAYS, AND FOR A
PARTY MEMBER WHO HAS DIED.
KHAN HAD BEEN ON THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL TO DEMAND SNAP ELECTIONS
IN PAKISTAN AFTER HE WAS OUSTED
IN A VOTE OF NO CONFIDENCE IN
PARLIAMENT JUST SIX MONTHS AGO.
ACCUSED OF BAD GOVERNANCE AND
MISMANAGING THE COUNTRIES
FEELING ECONOMY.
ISA, THERE IS STILL A LOT OF
UNEASE IN THE COUNTRY AT THE
MOMENT.
THERE HAVE BEEN PROTESTS LIKE
WE JUST HEARD IN THAT REPORT.
THERE ARE CALLS FOR A MASSIVE
RALLY BY OFFSHOOTS OF IMRAN
HUNTS PARTY HERE IN THE
CAPITAL.
THERE IS A LOT OF UNEASE.
THERE HAS BEEN PUSHBACK FROM
THE GOVERNMENT.
THIS DAY IS ALMOST LIKE A
MICROCOSM OF THE KIND OF UNEASE
AND POLITICAL POLARIZATION THAT
HAS SPREAD ACROSS PAKISTAN EVER
SINCE IMRAN KHAN WAS OUSTED.
HE'S BLAMED THE MILITARY.
HE'S BLAMED THE UNITED STATES
FOR SPOUTING A CONSPIRACY
AGAINST HIM.
THESE ARE UNEASY TIMES IN
PAKISTAN AND WE WILL JUST HAVE
TO WAIT AND SEE HOW THE DISEASE
OFFENSE MAY HAVE AN IMPACT OVER
THE WEEKEND, WHEN PEOPLE WILL
NOT BE GOING TO WORK.
WE ARE EXPECTING PEOPLE TO COME
OUT IN THE STREETS IN LARGE
NUMBERS.
THEY'VE BEEN COMING OUT IN THE
THOUSANDS FOR BUT IMRAN KHAN.
HE'S AN IMMENSELY POPULAR
POLITICIAN, OR FORMER
CRICKETING SUPERHERO.
HE'S A BIG DEAL HERE IN
PAKISTAN AND TODAY'S EVENTS
HAVE REMINDED PAKISTANIS OF
WHAT HAPPENED JUST 15 YEARS AGO,
WHEN ANOTHER FORMER PRIME
MINISTER --
WAS ASSASSINATED AT A SIMILAR
POLITICAL RALLY JUST HERE IN --
.
IT HAS REMIN